-Hey, guys, it is Friday,
and that is usually, yeah,
Fri-yay
That's what Tariq says.
It's Friday, that's usually when
I take care of some business,
I get some things done,
you know,
but the day just got
completely away from me.
I spend all day
playing online poker.
And I completely forgot to write
out my weekly thank-you notes.
So now I know it's
during the show,
but if you don't mind,
I thought I'd take this time
to write out my thank-you notes
right now,
is that okay with you?
Appreciate it.
Can I get some thank-you note
writing music please.
Thank you,
Trump's defense lawyer,
for somehow managing to be the
most embarrassing legal story
in the same week
that had Zoom cat lawyer.
How did he pull that one off?
Thank you,
$8,000 Louis Vuitton sweater,
for looking like someone
covered themselves with glue
and then moshed
at a Yo Gabba Gabba! concert.
Thank you,
breakfast in bed,
for giving me 20 minutes
of a nice breakfast
in exchange for eight hours
of sleeping in muffin crumbs.
[ Light cheers and applause ]
Muffin crumbs.
I feel like muffin tops
has gotten a little out of hand.
-Yeah, something else
is like a loaf loaf topped.
-Yeah, not even muffin anymore
at this point.
And it's just it just
totally ruins the bottom now.
-Yeah, it really does.
-Disappointing.
It's just just take the bottom
out of the equation.
-Why don't they
just sell muffin tops?
-Tops only, yeah.
Call 'em scones.
-Ahh.
[ Light laughter ]
-But then you know
you got a scone.
Scones aren't moist
like muffins.
That's the one time
I heard the word moist
and didn't cringe.
I agree with you. Yeah.
Scones are dry.
It's almost like
you're mixing it in your mouth.
-Yeah, right?
-To make something else.
-Yeah.
I don't I don't do all the work.
You've got to do all the mixing.
And if you put that added
muffin tin, you make a muffin.
-You're on to something, Jimmy.
-I know, man.
I gotta to call, I gotta call
the Bisquick people.
Yeah, we don't. Sorry.
Yeah. We don't.
No, we don't run
the family business.
And you got you call.
This is Fred Bisquick.
I'm into like video, video
director and stuff like that.
But my brother.
Mark. Mark's more at what?
-[ Imitates voice on line ]
-Uh-huh.
-Scones?
-[ Imitates voice on line ]
-Sure, sure, sure.
Again, this is Fred Bisquick.
I don't run that part
of the family business.
I'm more like, you know,
wedding video editing,
stuff like that.
So but if you need
any of that stuff like you,
give me a call, okay?
Call me back.
-[ Imitates voice on line ]
Are you married?
-Alright. Yeah. Well, anyway,
actually my brothers here
Do you want to talk to him?
-[ Imitates voice on line ]
-Okay, hold on.
Hello.
No, no, I'm sorry, I'm just
eating a scone. [ Coughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, bouquets,
for apparently being French
for a $200 pile of dead plants.
Aw, hey, come on.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, sidewalk puddles,
or, as New Yorkers call them,
the winter long jump.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, curbside pickup,
being the closest
I'll ever get to feeling
like a NASCAR driver
with my own pit crew.
It's like.
Thank you, long johns,
for not going by your full name,
lengthy Jonathans.
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Gosh.
Thank you, ski lifts,
for being the most exciting way
to feel like dry cleaning.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank you notes.